You know what? I have been staring at
this setup for months now and something
just felt off. Don't get me wrong, I
love technology, but somewhere between
the notifications, the tabs, the
constant connectivity, I've lost
something. When did my desk become a a
command center instead of a place to
think?
So, I'm trying something different
today. I'm stripping it all back, the
monitor, the MacBook, and even the
mechanical keyboard that I spent way too
much money on. And I'm creating a space
to think, [music] to write, to do
meaningful work. But, here's what I'm
realizing, your best work is not about
having
>> [music]
>> more tools, it's about having fewer
barriers between thinking of new ideas
and bringing them to life.
So, maybe the best technology isn't
[music] the newest technology and maybe
it's the technology that actually gets
out of your way. And sometimes you need
to go backwards
to go forwards. And for me, I want to
live where I'm known for writing books,
not writing work emails. Which is
exactly why I think I'm going to love
this new writing setup. And maybe you
will, too.